with the release of Pola on Netflix
right around the corner I thought I'd
check the movie out to let you know
whether it's worth staying in this
weekend to watch it or not firstly if
you're not into hyper violent
over-the-top often crass action movies
and polar is not for you
from pretty much the beginning to end it
feels like a cross between smokin aces
and a softcore porn movie with a
slightly better script how much you
enjoy this film will deeply depend on
your preferences and love of all things
pop culture there are clear winks to
John wick Metal Gear Solid and a vast
variety of comic books that will make
you either love or hate the movie in the
film we follow the Hitman and the Black
Kaiser who has recently been forced into
retirement in order to avoid paying him
his pension the assassin unit that hired
him had put a hit out on his head and
the film revolves around him taking them
down there's a few little neat twists
and turns thrown in there for good
measure but this is pretty by the
numbers Mads Mikkelsen does a fine job
in what was arguably his most stoic
performance ever
and he keeps things grounded whilst the
action around him goes into the extreme
unfortunately not everybody delivers on
this level of quality with Matt Lucas
being terribly missed cast to the point
you feel like he thinks he's on an
episode of Little Britain the other hit
men on anywhere is near interesting as
they should be and there are quite a few
moments that fall flat because of it
tonally Poehler doesn't seem to know
whether it wants to be a sincere story
or to just ham it up a lot of the time
and this leads to it feeling slightly
unbalanced however to its credit the
action is phenomenal and once you've
settled into the aesthetic of the film
I'm sure that you have a lot of fun with
it
Poehler is a tough one to really
recommend to people as it definitely
isn't for everyone but personally I had
a lot of fun with it and it's hyper
violent crime drama reminded me of films
like Robocop in a good way whilst it may
not be worth canceling your Friday night
for Poehler still is a lot of fun and
that's why it gets a 7 out of 10 so are
you excited for Poehler
have you seen it and if so what did you
think of it comment below and let me
know and if you enjoyed this video
please like it and make sure you keep an
eye out for my ending explained
breakdown of the
which is coming very shortly this is a
channel for people who are mad into
movies so if that's the kind of thing
you like hit subscribe thanks again for
taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]